il y à cary à 48 ans et toujours son
visage d'enfant au bout du crayon dérive
son créateur le dessinateur suisse était
présent ce week-end pour une séance de
dédicaces j'aime bien les petites indien
j'aime bien les illustrations un livre
avec lequel nous on a appris on a
découvert la bd et mes enfants aussi ont
découvert la bd appris à lire avec avec
et karim
voilà c'est une bd
plutôt sympa avec des animaux bon enfant
ça m'a surpris qu'il allait créer autant
50 ans de dessins une rétrospective de
carrière exposé à l'hôtel de ville de
versailles
yakari est née entre deux stroumpfs
j'étais chez peyo comme j'avais 20 ans
et j'avais du temps parce que peyo était
déjà un homme d'affaires avisé et le
matin j'étais assez libre de faire ce
que je voulais c'était surtout l'après
midi et la nuit qu'on travaillait sur le
schtroumpfissime je cherchais des
personnages et comme n'y avait pas de
petit indien ni dans tata ni dans spirou
me suis dit c'est serait sympa de faire
une histoire avec un petit indien mais
dérive n'est pas seulement l'auteur des
aventures du petit indien le far west et
son amour des chevaux guide ses coups de
crayon ce qui me fascine chez les
indiens plus que le western lui-même la
vie des indiens leur spiritualité leur
perception de la nature et des animaux
m'a toujours fasciné et je peux pas j'ai
passé beaucoup de temps à expliquer à
valoriser ça à travers la bande dessinée
j'ai rencontré des indiens qui m'ont dit
que c'était très proche de ce qu'ils
vivaient un 40e album des aventures du
petit indien est en préparation et les
secrets de son poney petit tonnerre
continueront à être dévoilé à son tour
patty de nerfs
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]